Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Subnautica.
The ghosts are still chasing us,
but we got a lot of stuff to do
and not a lot of time to do it,
so I'm gonna get right into the quick of this.
And I'm gonna skoodle-oot my way over to the
only other alien cache that I have not found
and I'm gonna find it very good today
because I know exactly where it is.
It is at -554, -534, 1521
and the more intensely you say it, the more realistic it becomes
and I'm currently at 800, -11, 53...1!
So I'm close...
...and by "close" I mean I'm not anywhere near close
and I'm actually as far away as I possibly can be.
BUT, I'm gonna go there because I need to get more ion- ion crystals
because I don't think there's a way to get them just yet.
In the future, I've been told
that there is a development build that is going to have
a WHOOOOLE BUNCH of ion crystals
more of those things that I can just mine.
You know, the dangerous ability of
shoving your diamond drill into a nuclear bomb
and then just hoping that it's not gonna blow you to shit.
That sort of thing? Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
But along the way, because I'm pretty sure
that it's pretty close to here
I'm gonna go to the lifepod that's carrying
Mongolian emissary Jochi Khasar
because I don't know why, but it made it seem like
they were talking about his funeral before he was actually dead
which normally I can appreciate
but in this specific... endeavor
I don't think that's very good for him or me
so I'm gonna find out what's happening in this zombie lifepod very soon
and in the meantime, I've got more comments to read.
The first one is by Chuckle Bones:
"There is a tool in Subnautica called the transfuser
"that you can use to take samples of DNA from other creatures"
"and either put them into other creatures or inject them into yourself."
Perhaps this could be the means of a cure
which makes a lot of sense considering
they're gonna have the Sea Emperor in the game
which means that the Sea Emperor is going to be
the only thing in the game that is immune
to the Carar virus which is infecting
absolutely everything in this world
and that's important because the Carar virus
is in me and every other living thing
and it somehow breached containment I can only assume
when the Aurora crashed down into the planet it actually skewed the entire containment system
just crashed and destroyed everything!
There was supposed to be there..
And oh my god, there is Lifepod 3
Well, I didn't expect to be skating over you just like that
I hope I hit you on the way over
I got the Mongolian emissary Jochi Khasar waiting for me
Hey, are you frickin' holding on to me, Lifepod 3?
It's just some guy, DESPERATELY, grabbing on to Big Box Barry
No! Please! I'm alive!
No, come on, shut up dude.
Get out of my face! I got the emissary of Mongolia
Jochi Khasar, WAITING for me to bury his dead body!
WAY more important than your LIVING body,
Get the fuck off of me.
You stupid Lifepod 3
So I'm gonna go over there,
and uh, thank you Chuckle Bones
I will get these names on the lockers very soon-
Or the name plates, which I discovered that I do have, very soon
And then Lindsay S.,
♪ The noises in the sub are driving Mark insane ♪
♪ Mark insane, Mark insane! ♪
♪ The noises on the sub are driving Mark insane ♪
♪ All through the sea! ♪
Nothing really more to that comment than just that song there
Which is pleasant enough, I mean,
resonates with me, in my heart here, so that I think I feel more at home
when I'm in the dark depths of my mind, and the sea.
And then the next one is Cameron Douglas,
who said: "Build an aquarium to plant koosh and creepvine."
So the aquarium,
That was my voice crack, from puberty.
The aquarium is the inside-the-base device that is
just a large tank filled with water, and in that I can grow koosh and creepvine.
which means that I'll have a steady source of it.
And I also think you can do it in the exterior grow beds outside of your base.
So I'm gonna experiment this with bor- before I actually go down in the deep because
the deep- having a base down there is nothing more than an ego trip.
Literally the only reason the only reason why I wanna do that is for my own ego
and I know it's bad, but I'mma do it anyway-
Eeuhh God I'm in the mushroom area
I can't see shit. Do I not have my lights on?
I don't.  Okay I'm gonna turn my lights on real quick here
'cause I can't see garbo.
BOOP.
There we go that's better.
A little barter- *chokes* a little better anyway so
let's see if we can get a camera here.
How do we get the camera?
Welp I've forgotten how to get the camera.
What?
Oh that's right its the button. Duh. There it is.
*whooshy camera noises*
OHHkay where are we now?
Nah. Nah.
There we go-
ohhh pretty!
Oh you're so pretty.
Ohmygawd.
I wonder if there any- ever anything that I could actually do with these mushrooms
because it seemed weird that there were just all these mushrooms here
and yet, what could you have done about it?
Oh did I miss-
DID I MISS THE MONGOLIAN EMISSARY JOCHI KASSAR?
I think I might have missed the emissary Jochi Kassar.
Is he around here somewhere?
I bet tha- OOHHHHHHHKAY I hit somethin'.
Hmm. Don't know what, mighta' been a mushroom.
Alright. So he's around here somewhere
Whoo do we got?
JOCHI KASSAR?
Oh. Emissary Jochi Kassar is right below me!
I'MMM gonna go-
*mystical whooshy boat noises*
against my better judgement- I'm gonna go without my th- eUOHHH.
Well!
Jochi Kassar doesn't seem to be here!
And there seems to be large things that are missing from the terrain here!
Thaaat's weird.
Sooo....
Whaat the hell does this mean?
What the fuck?
Well that's super weird!
Okay apparently Mongolian Emissary Jochi Kassar is the ghost
that has been haunting me this entire time I've been here.
And I'm gonna take this.
'Scuse me.
I gotta creature egg! I don't know what it's to but I got it.
Okay! So that's the only thing that I wanted to do here
so I'm gonna just skip ahead, uh, and go to the um-
*mystical whooshy boat noises*
I'm gonna go to the-
(Welcome aboard, Captain.)
-the thing. The alien cache location.
So I'll be right back when I get over there. But very soon. Very, verry soon.
wHOA! HEY! WHOOAA HEY WHOAHEYWHOA! WHOA! WHOA! WHOA! WHOA! Whoa! Whoa!
Mountain! Where d'you come from? Where'd you go?
🎵Where'd you come from cotton-eyed Joe?🎵
Oooo. There is a lot of supplies here
so I'm gonna make a pit stop right here and I'm gonna gather as many supplies as I can-
I'm also gonna dump my inventory right now because I don't need it!
Here you go Grom! Oh no Grom's got the koosh.
Oh and also Whispering Potatoes, who has the coolest name I've ever heard and yes,
the potatoes do whisper at me in the night,
said: "MARK! DO YOU STILL HAVE YOUR KITTY POSTER?"
"'CAUSE IF YOU DON'T I'M GONNA HAVE TO COME OVER THERE AND TALK WITH YOU"
"ABOUT HOW THE IMPORTANT THAT POSTER IS... Please say you still have it? Please?"
And of course,
I have the Keep Calm Kitty poster.
I would never leave home without the Keep Calm Kitty poster!
Whaddya think I am, a barbarian?
NO! I've always got the Keep Calm Kitty poster on me at all times because I need it!
Anyway, that's all I need about that-
SO I'm gonna gather-
*mystical whooshy boat noises*
-and it's just about day too, so I'm gonna get me some shupplies-
Sklidoosh! Skli-klop.
Sklidoosh!
Sskiiiiiiiilorrrrrrp!
Gawd daaammiiiittt
Ahh, the Stillsuit! I knew I needed fiber mesh for SOMETHING!
Oh I can make the Stillsuit and then I can drink my own piss,
which is the only reason I wanted to have that in the first place,
and no one is going to question me at all because it's a good thing,
it's a good thing to drink your own piss because it's a survival tactic,
and no one here can JUDGE me,
especially you, KAREN, 'cause it's important for surrrrvivaal.
Everybody understand me? Now I just gotta find where I put my fiber meeesssh- right there,
And now I'mma make me a Stillsuit because radiation is no longer a concern,
so I don't need it. Everybody understand? It's for SURVIVAL.
It's a SURVIVAL THING.
(Stillsuit equipped. Capturing body moisture.)
Hell yeah, Karen, yes I am, and you wouldn't judge me about that would you?
I don't think you would anyway, you better not because that's- that's bad, you shouldn't do that,
you shouldn't do that.
*reading* "The status of the Aurora's crew and the ship's long-distance communications relay is inter-indeterminate."
"If any of the ship's data coils remain intact it may be possible to salvage this information."
Really?
Is there a reason for me to go back to the Aurora?
I mean I know in the last one it said that there might- I said that there might be
but that was just a might-maybe based on what somebody said.
So maybe, maybe I will be going back to the Aurora-
*cacophony of Karens*
-very soon.
Oh sh*t. Exploded my spleen. *CUE MARKTAGE*
EEEESPPLOOSH
Bloombadoomdabala. BLOOSH
uH- *fart noise*
BADABABDABDA
*faster* BIPBOOPBADABDADABIPBOP
SHHHPLAFF (monster noise)
WHEY. HEY. HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY HEY HEEEEEEYYYYY, EY EY EY EY EY
Heuuuyyey... gesquoopy *END MARKTAGE*
ALRIGHT, we're all done farmin' on we go, to the point of the....
*chokes*....thingamabober of things.
We're gonna do daat.
Oh, before I do that though, before I do dat
there's one more thing that I wanna do.
Um, and a lot of people have been telling me to do this for quite a while
because I don't know why I've been so hesitant to do this
but I'm gonna make myself
*suddenly deeper* a beeeeed
and I'm only gonna make it for ONE PERSON
BECAUSE ALL OF MY FRIENDS ARE DEEEAAAAD :D
Hahahahahahehehehehe *sobs hysterically*
*cries enough to fill the ocean with his tears*
I'll make it here by the driver's seat 'cause
why do I need to make it anywhere- else, everyone's dead *sniffs*
Yeah, just right there's good for me
Yeah, okay, that's good
Yeah, I don't need-
If there was someone who could use that console I'd- I'd put 'em there
but they- I'd- I don't have anybody I've got nobody
*laughs sadly*
Just a bed...
Yeaah, right there, so I can sleep and all the fish can watch me sleep
and then it's LIKE people are wanting to be around me,
except it's not, so yeah :(
Anyway
I'm gonna sleep my nightmares away
I'm just gonna lay down my head and rest my weary bones
I'm gonna sleep again- I can't sleep okay.
*laughs* I got reclaimed water! Oh good. Good. Alright.
Yuum. Let me just drink THAT piss. And sweat. The mixture of it.
That's a good thing to wake up to, I'm pretty sure that's a balanced breakfast,
Tony the Tiger would be proud of me.
Yeaah.
*sniffs* Anyway, gonna carry on to the cache now
because I-I'm now very sad and lonely.
Alriiigght, we are getting CLOSE! I need to diiiive, diiiive, diiiive
So I think... I think this this one is
located in the blood kelp zone that I
actually left the, uh, Lost River from.
There is another entrance to the Lost River
and it is near here, right in this area
with these weird, chained, floating rocks
Or maybe they're suspended by the...
weird blood kelp that's here because
IT'S ALL UNNATURAL HERE and I do not like it.
Maybe I should get some samples of this, but I don't think it's gonna be any use to me.
Alright, I must be close- yeah, I'm- I'm right on top of it.
I need to DIIIVE DIIIVE DIIIVE DIIIVE-
oh hey, crab-squiddy.
Oh squidaloo squidala
squidalee squidalolo
Yeesh
It might be over this ridge.
No it's right below me somewhere
so there's got to be...
a way down below
Hey Warper, buddyboo!
How about I ram into you?
Would that be fun?
Okay, so I think I've got to go...
either down there or down there
I'm thinking down here is gonna a better way for me to get in.
Let me start navigating using these sons of bitches.
Oh yeah, that looks bad.
That looks like a whole lot of bad,
but it looks like a whole lot of where I'm supposed to go
so let's get GOIN'
Oh yeah.
Oh, that's scary.
Hey buddy!
Heeeyyy
How you doing?
Alriiiiight okay.
It's somewhere around here
and I definitely haven't been to this one before
because this is a...
This is territory that I really haven't explored
this whole blood kelp area is just
completely foreign to me.
Like... o-of all the areas that I've explored in Subnautica
this has to be the LEAST
the LEAST populated
of any of these
Ooof
Well *sigh*
OH! THAT'S IT!
Oh that is it! Right there!
Okay, I'm gonna hop out
I'm not even going to take Mr. Fister
Ooh it's weird being closed off like this and also...
attached on a ramp here...
But I'm going to go into there
and I'm gonna brave this
because I'm a big brave boy...
But err... here we go...
And I imagine it's not gonna be that bad 'cause there's gotta be some air down here somewhere...
or maybe there's not and I'mma be risking my life-
OH NO! OH NO!
It requires a partifact! I don't have a partifact, I need to go get one!
Ooo, do I have enough diamond? EH SHIT.... SHIT
Alright, I'll be right back, I need to go get
either diamonds or everything I need to get through here... SHIIEETT.
SHIT!
AH! I gotta diamond. Okay, we're good! We're good!
Everything's good! We're good!
The siren is calling for me out there,
which is leading me into the rocks that I'm gonna crash into,
but enough about that, let's get our way...
into this son-of-a-bitch cave...
and hopefully, not die a horrible death.
Yeeuh.
Okay.
So I don't know what else is in here besides more ion crystals,
but we're about to find out by plapping this thing in there.
Man, I wish that I could USE that again
I don't know why it's gotta be all... temporary, but-
Eeuuhhh.
Ohkay.
Alrighty then, don't know what that noise is all about,
I'll take youuu, and you, and uh- ooo, data! Yes please!
Alien Sanctuary B?
Yoouu, and youuu, thank youu,
thank you very muuch.
Okay, so I got those, it looked like that was the only thing in here.
I'll read the data and I just remembered that I need to read the data
from that crashed ship that I found, uh, in the last episode,
I didn't quite get to that, so I'm gonna do that immediately now...
HUBEDA HUBEDA HUBEDA GET ME IN!
Okay, there we go.
So now I'm gonna go up here by my bed, of which I am very lonely,
and I'mma raise my ship out of here
and then I'm gonna reeeeaad.
Yeah, you know what, we're good here in the view of the dark depths
and no escape anywhere, alright, it's good enough for me.
Okay, I'mma turn down the lights and get real moody for storytime here.
Yeah, that's good and creepy- oh my god, that's creepy.
Eeuhh, why do I have my bed in here?
I dunno! I'm DESPERATE.
Alright, here we go.
Data bank, technical- nah, that wouldn't have been it-
da-downloads, we had public documents, so!
"The Charter!"
"Definitions: Trans-gov - defacto control of at least one system?"
Huh?
"Citizen - a person who consents consciously or implicitly to the authority of a recognized trans-gov,"
"The Charter, Trans-System Federation, Trans-System Phasegate..."
Huh.
"Each trans-gov is to have an equal right to the most
extensive basic liberty compatible with a similar liberty for others."
"Each trans-gov has the right to own phasegates and planetary infrastructure."
"Each trans-gov has an obligation to share phasegate access with other trans-govs on equal terms."
"Each trans-gov has an obligation to financially maintain and comply with the TSF."
"Each trans-gov has the right to self-government, subject to the restrictions laid out below."
"No trans-gov may develop weapons and technologies outlied in- outlawed in appendix 91."
"No trans-gov shall engage in population abuse."
That's not a lot of rules.
So what this means is that in these- in this universe where humans have expanded to the stars
and they've- they've traveled the world and their universe and the galaxy
and they've inhabited many of these locations.
It means that... when you have,
uh, control of at least one solar system and phasegate
you have a trans-government, which means you have the right to self-authority,
but also, you must be- under the Trans System Federation.
Which is very interesting because
I don't know how big that is.
But anyway,
"Comparing the data on this terminal with stored translations have revealed
new information about this alien sanctuary."
"The antechamber consists of a series of main data hubs, each adorned with an ion crystal.
These are networked up to the main terminal in parallel, presumably to ensure data integrity over time."
"Unprecedented data complexity. Stored data was scanned into the system at the local terminal.
Original data source was organic in nature. Evidence suggests that this antechamber served as
a sanctuary of last resort for the aliens that built it.
"In the event of catastrophe, they would retreat here and somehow transfer themselves
to the data hubs for preservation."
"It is unclear whether other members of the alien species ever returned here,
or how many souls are backed up on the hubs, but the data stored is far too complicated-
complex, to reconstitute with the little information available."
So, that is actually really interesting,
because what that MEANS... is that there are... precursor aliens STORED in the computers of their technology.
They aren't just like, they aren't just organic beings.We've already covered this.
They're data. So that means, each of those hubs... powered by the ion crystals,
which I just removed, thank you very much.
Uh, but also powered by the thermal plant down below,
store, basically the lives of all the aliens in the hopes that they could be downloaded into bodies again.
But who knows when that could be?
They tried to escape the virus,
so they escaped the virus by leaving their organic forms.
And then...
They just waited.
I think, they're waiting in cyberspace. Who knows if they're even aware of it, or if it's like a SOMA situation
where you don't know unless you're powered up.
Which is super weird.
I mean, it'd be kinda like a prison if you were aware in the computer, and not able to MOVE.
I mean, that'd be fucking weird.
I don't know.
Yyyyeeah. Ooh, man. Alright-
I think I've already these- yeah, I did.
I.. I've already gotten these, so.
That is..
preeetty messed up. SO.
ANYWAY.
I think.. I thinky think.. Yeah.
I'm all out of time for this episode.
So thank you everybody so much for watching. In the next one, I'm going to make my way back to BubbleButt.
And HOPEFULLY, reunite once again and then continue my journey in to building the infrastructure
that I need to carry on and build that base.
... Down in the deep depths.
And EVENTUALLY,
Kill that Sea Dragon.
Cause, I wanna.. I wanna have a trophy.
And I'm gonna kill that son of a bitch.
I'VE ALREADY DONE A GOOD AMOUNT OF DAMAGE TO HIM,
Unless, there are, there are two of them.
No, I guess the one in the Lava Zone is a different one than the one above.
Cause THERE ARE TWO.
There are DEFINITELY TWO.
If they ever get freaky in the middle of the night, I'm not gonna like being around them at then.
But we'll see that when we see the next one.
So THANK you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see YOU
IN THE NEXT VIDEO.
BUH-BYE!